We're going to try to get our world
modeling stuff working today.
I believe where we left off.
Uh, this might need to be rebooted. One
sec.
Let me reboot this container and then
we'll show the uh the current
result which is that we have a world
model that trains above random PF.
That's pretty much it.
So here it is.
So the question is
how we effectively take this from this
like super unstable thing
to something that we can actually use
effectively.
You know, I kind of just want to spend a
little time sort of thinking through all
the different things here.
Welcome something.
Okay.
So
what have we have done? like we have
done.
I think we have the recurrent state base
model,
right? And then we have like the
losses
and then we have like directional
correctness.
and like generally not that good.
Hey Tim, shout out to your barber.
It's the uh the same place I've been
going since I was in undergrad. Little
Vietnamese shop. They're always super
quick. Never giving me a bad haircut.
We trust the Vietnamese in matters of
food and in matters of uh barbering.
I was just saying yesterday, I wish we
could just replace McDonald's with a a
good fur chain.
It would be a market improvement for the
country.
and also the compute scale as well, All
right.
Can you show the previous results of
your code?
We have a thing that does substantially
better than random consistently on
cartpole.
This is no by no means a good result. It
is at most a directionally correct
result,
but it is at least a starting point.
You know, the replay might actually be
important here, right?
Cuz like the replay slows down the pace
at which you're getting new data.
actually world predicting. Yeah, there's
a reconstruction loss.
It's not pixels, right? We're not
training on pixels, but there is a
reconstruction loss.
I mean, ultimately, right, there are
only two sources of error. Your RL is
bad or your world model is bad, right?
If I were to like grade these on how
important I think they are, right?
scale. You really shouldn't need scale
for cart pole. This is like a C
tuning. Tuning actually usually makes a
big difference. So there shouldn't be
anything here different. So that's a B.
The tricks.
Let me see what specific tricks they
have.
OB sim log
advantage norm.
The only thing possible is maybe the KL
balance, but we're not seeing that loss.
So other than KL,
Okay.
And then there's also like
maybe like I have like not done sampling
or gradients correctly.
Uh compute scaling
I think this is maybe like a B. It might
just fundamentally take a little bit
more compute with this setup.
The replay is actually the only thing
that I think is like an A
like in the sense of maybe like how
likely these things are to matter.
So I think what we do,
we implement a replay buffer.
We scale a little bit compute and tuning
and we see if we can get cartpole stable
and we go from there.
Would an onpaw world model risk biasing
heavily to current policy and mess
the world model up?
Uh,
can that happen?
I don't think that can happen, Tim,
because the world model is not trained
on hallucinated data. The world model is
trained on the current data.
But I don't really think you can mess
the world model up. I think it's pretty
hard to mess the world model up with
with the agent. I think more so you mess
up the agent with the world model being
behind.
I could be wrong, but that's what I
would guess.
This is way better scaling than on Paul,
right?
Wouldn't it only see current policy
states?
The world model.
Yes. The world model sees states from
the current policy like actually acted
uh inter actually
enacted on the environment though.
So yes, training the world model is
dependent on
the policy.
You'd have to collapse the policy to
like start feeding the world model bad
data, which I suppose you can get.
So maybe
going to put this on the side.
We're going to try replay buffer.
You don't need this.
Okay. So
next thing I need
Yeah. So like this.
Now we know if the buffer is getting
filled up.
And then this is going to be the index
is going to go up to full segments.
Okay.
You're going to do a certain number of
mini batches.
like this, right?
And then at the end,
we're going to
shift replay.
Okay, which is going to be
um
so like max hold
And then what we do is we do
self.obations
Let me see if this works.
I believe this does.
I wish I could disable this multi-line
complete thing.
Okay. So, what this should do is this
should just keep the most recent
segments
So, this it's fails on the second time
through.
Let's see what I've messed up here. And
then this will be like a simple replay
buffer.
Actually, this is a good question for
somebody that I don't know.
Is there actually like um a much more
copy efficient way to implement a ring
buffer that makes sense in this context?
Oh, yeah. You totally can just Well,
there's a good way to implement a ring
buffer, but as soon as I do prioritized
replay anyways, then there's no
efficient way to do it. Actually,
does anybody know like there's no
efficient way to do a ring buffer when
you're doing like prioritized replay,
right? because you're just like grabbing
arbitrary samples and overwriting them.
Wait. Refer to the same address in
memory.
Wait, why is that a problem that they
refer to the same address in memory?
What's this say?
Let's ask rock.
This is like a weird obscure thing. I
would think that you should be able to
do it.
Oh yeah, this is not mine. This Don't
worry, this not my account. I was seeing
if I could get a username.
Oh, it's it is because it's a mem copy,
right?
I answered my own question. It's because
it's one mem copy.
you should actually be able to make that
work to be There.
Well, that's um like that's
substantially more stable.
It's not perfect,
but that's way better than before,
right?
literally just from having a buffer.
Okay. And then if I do,
let me just make sure I'm testing the
thing. I think I am. Oops.
One second. Be right back.
we're going to try a little bit of
compute scaling.
Yeah. Yeah. Still quite unstable in
fact.
That's like massively better though,
right?
We have to just fix the instability now.
It's no longer bad. It's just unstable.
Yeah. So, if this thing stops just
collapsing itself every two seconds,
it'll be good.
Let's just like look at the parameters
that they have in the paper.
We're going to get this [ __ ] to work
today.
I'm going to have this working
at least as like a decent bit and then
we're going to have uh
I'm going to get it cleaned up as best I
can and then I'm going to have myself a
nice dinner and that's going to be a
good Saturday's worth of work.
We're going to take quite a bit of
fiddling. I want to get not stuck on
like silly things all day. I think that
we got a pretty clear-cut plan now.
Okay, so experience replay
uniform replay buffer with an online
queue.
Each mini batch is formed first from
non-over overlapping trajectories,
then filled up uniformly
with uniformly sampled trajectories from
the replay buffer.
Latent states into the replay buffer
during data collection.
to initialize the world model on replay
trajectories. What?
That seems stupid.
Write the fresh latent states of the
rollout buffer back into it.
We found Oh, experience replay to
improve the performance of dreamer. We
opt for un Okay.
fresh latent states.
Does anybody understand why you would do
this?
This part seems weird.
We parameterize the amount of training
via the replay ratio.
The fraction of time steps trained on
per time step collected of the
environment. Yes, without action repeat.
Okay. Yeah. So, this is sample reuse.
Dividing
the replay ratio by the time steps in a
mini batch yields the ratio of gradient
up green steps to M steps.
Replay ratio of 32 on Atari with action
repeat of batch 14. One gradient step
328. So, we don't really care about
gradient steps per Msteps as much,
though it's useful to keep in mind
perhaps
This we should at least try.
That one actually seems like
They have very high replay ratios and
everything.
Minecraft is actually lower.
Bite they have super high
two to three hours of GPU compute.
That's insane.
Oh, because that's including um skip.
Okay.
All right. So these robustness
techniques which we know are [ __ ]
This is whatever
adaptive clip. Okay. Yeah. So that's
fine.
Larger capacity online Q storing and
updating latent states.
updating
latent states. That's weird.
Replay capacity of 5 million, right? 26.
Yeah, 5 million.
Wait, batch size is 16
like 64. So what is that? That is is
that 512?
No, that's 1024, right?
Yeah, this is so 1024.
So this is then actually if you go by
the ratios here, right?
This is
Yeah. So this is basically what this is
saying to me is that the replay is
actually changing quite slowly here,
right?
Because this is 16 * 64 1024 samples
in a batch.
So, how do we make this efficient with
our setup?
I think we just do
if I just do um
Well, we can't go that crazy, can we?
Don't want to go that crazy. Let's do
like 256
but that's 4096 batch size right that'll
actually happen automatically. play.
And then instead of doing update epochs,
we just do
I mean that's in a million a million
steps, not even. Right.
I wonder if it does eventually stabilize
or not.
See like that type of thing there.
Definitely getting weird spikes.
But the the potential is definitely
here.
I'm actually kind of curious if I just
shift this to breakout real quick.
Oh, you know what? It's not going to. We
have to Fine.
Hey, Kevin.
How's it going?
You'll actually probably be kind of
interested in this stuff here.
This seems to be at least so far the
most promising thing. I need to figure
out how to make it stable.
Why is it this unstable?
What's the idea?
Uh we're basically adapting world model
stuff from dreamer, stripping out the
[ __ ] parts and getting it into
actually efficient implementation with
puffer and we're going to see whether
this actually uh we're going to
essentially try to bridge the gap
between data efficient RL and compute
efficient RL in one implementation.
And why is it so unstable? That's the
big question.
We added the replay buffer. We added a
little bit of compute.
And then now it's very good, but it's
very unstable in a sense, right?
MX clause, representation loss,
reconstruction loss.
Not like learning rate or something
stupid either, right?
Like I could technically mess with that,
but I don't I really don't think that's
what it is.
I'm a bit confused as to how
supposed to clip these losses at one,
right?
I don't understand how you could
possibly be clipping these losses at
one, though.
Well, I guess at least now that we know
we have it somewhat correct, we need to
like
go through the reference a little bit.
Is there actually a good reference
implementation for this or not really?
I think there is like an actual good
one.
Try this pietorch one just so it's maybe
not completely insane.
This is like a weird direct port of the
jacks, I think.
Yeah. Yeah. This is like a direct port
of the jack, so it's going to be equally
weird shitty code.
where all the Jacks people need to like
stop eating glue or whatever.
Yeah, this is
this is not going to be really any more
helpful than the Jax's because they
literally wrote jacks and pietorrch,
which is even worse than Jacks and
Jacks,
but these are fine.
And then you clip the mens.
Okay, so you clip with a min. This is
actually good.
So I can use this version of it. But
then the question is
why does the KL not match up?
what's the expected KL of random
Oh, you know what? Hang on. I I can use
this for something.
So
you got post and prior
you get distra post
sample disc. So, okay, it just gives you
it gives you the initial thing back.
I just want to make sure this is
actually the logits
AL loss
tail divergence
We do
Hey, LOS.
It's like abysmal
how people write this code.
Okay, post and prior which come from
self dynamics observe
which is the RSSM. Okay. So it comes
from the output of observe.
I swear sometimes reading research code
it really does feel like I'm the only
sane person in the world.
Okay. So here it is. Uh you get items.
It's a dictionary with a bunch of stuff
in it.
obstep
whatever this dictionary is. It's
probably got like the stochastic and the
deterministic parts. Is this it?
Obstep, not observe. Obstep. Here we go.
Post prior. Okay. Okay. So you have
stochastic deterministic
stats
stochcastic is a sample
these are log jets.
Okay. So stochcastic and then deter is
the logits.
You know people good at lml here
entropy collapse
makes the model more deterministic.
advantages go to zero.
Pretty known issue with GRPO.
You not just have an entropy term on
that? That sounds horrifying. Um
I don't know. You can ask around. There
are a few people in the Discord
like that guy and a few others. They may
or may not answer that that stuff
because they do it professionally as
well. Um
I mean like RL in general will do that
unless you have a pretty heavy entropy
term.
It's not necessarily considered a bad
thing in a lot of cases, right?
And where was I? I lost my place.
Right there. We were doing that.
We're going to assume that prior and
post come from this
puffer world model going. It's actually
working. Um, we have it we have it
actually able to get to max score on the
task. It's just very unstable. And I'm
trying to figure out why it's unstable.
No, just car pulse so far. But this is
going to actually work.
It's just going to take me a little bit
of effort.
and you do not sample from this thing,
right?
I see. So, they're just like doing this
super heavily wrapped [ __ ] thing.
Can anybody tell me though you do
if you're going to like sample
categoricals from some logits, right?
But you want to do KL on uh between two
different distributions. You do the KL
between the logits not between the
samples. Right?
Hell between the normals. What do you
mean between the normals?
I'm like confused on this.
It's very difficult to actually figure
out because it's just wrapped in
horseshit.
not samples. Yeah,
you probably just do it on
Okay,
but then the D like I don't understand
why these losses are so low.
this is interesting.
We're not training a value function.
Looks like we're not training the value
function at all. Right.
I think I have the uh the value loss
wrong.
Star the puffer. By the way, if you're
here, you haven't started the puffer
yet. Star the puffer. It's free. It
helps me out a ton.
It's all open source work.
Having more stars gets this into more
eyes. And then that means I get to spend
more time on research and less time
looking for contracts because they come
to
Why does stars help? Because the bigger
the project gets, the more visibility it
has, the more that companies see it, and
then companies come to me asking for
contracts or when they check out the
project, they see it as an established
thing. And it makes it much much easier
on the business side for me uh to get my
work out there without having to spend
my time as much on that. And then I get
to spend more time on actually
developing the software, making it
easier to use. And as you can see here,
improving the core algorithms.
You like algo dev? Exactly. Because
algov means that we can actually solve
more problems and do more cool things.
I don't particularly like algov most of
the time. I'm fine doing this for a bit.
I way happier doing like the core
engineering on most of this stuff when I
can.
Oh, I do it so that this Well, I do it
because unfortunately we don't exactly
have a ton of contributors qualified to
do this type of stuff. This stuff is
really freaking hard.
But it's okay. I do it sometimes.
This gives you advantage plus value,
right? Advantage plus value.
And then
Right. So, this is always going to be
Yeah.
How the hell does this make sense?
Bandage thingy.
Oh, is this not normalized advantage?
Hang on.
Yeah. So you don't add the normalization
to this one.
It does.
The value function blows up a whole
bunch. It seems
way worse.
Let's go check out what is the value
clamping that I had before.
So, we have
Okay. So, this clipping is not relevant
when it's fully on policy, right?
Oh, wait, wait, wait. New value minus MB
values.
That's just MB values.
Okay. Okay. So this actually is not a
clip.
Yeah, there's no clamp on the value
function of this form actually.
So if I just do this,
already at
it. Shouldn't have to be a lower
learning rate. We'll try it real quick.
I don't think this is what it is, right?
I was doing the same exact thing just
slower.
New value minus MB value. So we clamp
this
to zero. So MB value is new value.
These are the same
and MB returns
bandages plus Are you
No, the value is supposed to be like
this.
Oh yeah. What happens if I actually if I
do this way? So this is the easy mode,
right? Basically this tells us uh
there's something core wrong if this
doesn't train.
Yeah. So there is something like core
wrong here.
The value function blowing up.
This is the easy training mode, right?
This takes out like a lot of the
guesswork.
Wait, what does this clipping actually
do?
No, these are the same.
So, this is telling me that there's
something fundamentally wrong, but I'm
not seeing
It's not this either. Good. That would
have made no sense if that worked.
All new value append value
takes H and Z.
doesn't take that.
still be able to learn
and a value
new log prop entropy for terminal
action.
it like
It couldn't have been training before,
right?
No, it was training something. It was
training something weird, wasn't it?
Hang on. Maybe I'm just getting confused
here then.
Don't know.
Oh, no. This uh
Yeah. Right. Right here. Right. This is
it.
Yeah. This is it. Okay. This is the
thing that actually trained
Still unstable, but that helps quite a
bit. All
right. So now
Well, the value loss didn't like
massively spike. It's high, but it's not
not like this is massively spiked or
anything, right?
Okay. Well, this is progress
somewhat at least
Do they have They don't have any
instabilities in this either, right?
16 segments of length 64. Is this
and 16 segments
length 64.
Wait, I need to like figure out
scale difference then.
Wait, we need to be 32x the scale of
this, right? Is it 16 * 32?
Is that correct?
We'd want 512 environments.
We're going to do a mini batch of
cuz isn't it 32ide
by
2048 segments? Wait a second. Wait a
second.
I wonder now if I do more update epox is
it better or worse.
Okay. So, we should have
some concerns then based on this.
reconstruct
H and Z, right?
Yeah, I think there are potentially some
detaches that I'm not seeing.
The world model parameters
are optimized end to end to minimize
prediction and dynamics
This has got to be a problem, right?
What's your initial KL here?
Tiny, right? These
are both tiny.
you guys saying something about how
world models you can efficiently do on
policy on RL assuming this RL is true
elaborate on what that well the idea
here is that because the environment is
the world model right you can just do on
policy RL with respect to the world
model you can get data from your
environment you use it to train the
world model and because you're doing RL
on the world model instead of on the
data you don't have to actually deal
with any of the off policy corrections
you would normally need if you wanted to
stick a replay buffer
uh into like on policy RL
and that's actually pretty powerful.
Yeah. So this is
this is the sample. Oh,
These look like the same under the log
distribution.
and encode
H previous
X
going to be initially this
right.
Then you get your
What are you doing? I'm trying to do
it's like a dreamer v3 derivative thing
uh in puffer so high performance. I'm
trying to work out some problems with
the algorithm.
Could be something with this, right?
Maybe if I go check the reference
implementation and how they're doing.
The problem with their sampling is so
screwy, right?
Maybe I can figure out
does anybody understand how the uh the
representation portion like the
stochastic representation is actually
used
in all the decoder heads
like I would think it's just that you
take one sample or like one set of 32
samples right and then you use the same
set of samples for all the decoder
heads.
I don't know if this is actually how it
works though.
want to learn coding like you. But how?
I mean, I have some educational material
on my uh
guide here. This contains my best
general advice for programming in ML.
It's on my XRS 5341.
The idea of this stream is basically
watch um watch cutting edge RL research
done live.
I mean, I'm a researcher. I stream all
of my work.
Okay, so they call get feet on the
prior.
So hold on, hold on. So the reward
prior,
where's the continue prior? Open L.
get used?
Oh, this is so bad.
Okay, wait. They have reward in here.
I don't see it.
Oh, here it is. Wait. So they do
dynamics get feet of posterior
and then they call this on it. So
dynamics get feature
in head of feature.
Recap progress you've made so far in
this saga. Uh let me make let me not
lose my train of thought but in a
minute. Yes.
Okay. So, this looks like I am doing it
correctly. This doesn't look like
they're getting a new sample.
So,
When they make
yeah, that looks like I think I have
this right then. So, unfortunately then
that can't be the issue. So, quick recap
for you since you asked. Um, I went to
RLC a couple weeks ago. Actually, I've
got the shirt on.
And I got I came back with a whole bunch
of ideas for core algorithm dev. I was
trying to figure out, okay, um, is
sample reuse something we really need to
think about? How do we improve sample
efficiency? I talked to a bunch of
people on on policy research. I got a
bunch of ideas on papers to look at. I
did a pretty comprehensive eval of a lot
of off policy research
and it's a mess. Like really that stuff
just doesn't seem to work well. Um I
actually don't really think that there's
that much value uh there compared to
other things which then since that takes
this huge chunk out of uh of possible
algorithms there not that many other
options. is you get to search and you
get to world models which are kind of
related in a way cuz you need a world
model to do search on most problems just
the use of it is different. So I came
back to dreamer v3. I also checked
efficient zero v2. Uh dreamer v3 is a
paper that's caused me a bunch of grief
in the past because we've did a huge
follow-up study to this paper and half
of the reasoning in it is wrong. But I
think that the results are still correct
and independently now with mu0
follow-ups efficient zero v1 and two uh
we see that world modeling of some type
at least with search is quite effective.
So what I'm trying to do now is figure
out if there's a way that one we can
just like get some of the results from
this, reproduce some of the results with
code that doesn't suck and then uh two
get it into puffer in a way where it's
not just like have a super slow
inefficient implementation that is uh
you know that it's very data efficient
but very compute inefficient where
puffer is very uh compute efficient but
data inefficient. I want to make one
algorithm that you can kind of tune so
it's either sample efficient, data
efficient or uh compute efficient and
that is what I'm trying to do now. And
the key the key thing is I'm just stuck
on a lot of the uh a lot of just minor
things with dreamer and making it
stable. I'm running it on a very very
simple benchmark which is cartpole. Uh
it can solve it very quickly but the
learning is incredibly incredibly
unstable and I am trying to figure out
why. Uh there are several reference
implementations, but they're all based
on each other and they all suck. So
there's kind of limited stuff out there
that I can actually use. But uh I'm
doing my best to get this stuff into
Puffer. That is the extended recap for
you. Use a restroom and grab myself a
drink and then I will continue on this
It is quite possible I've realized that
I do not have a bug and it's just
fiddly.
Hello, welcome.
There are a couple differences I have
neglected to uh account for, I believe.
so by eight-fold sample reuse, you're
supposed to have most of the benefit,
right?
Eight-fold sample reuse.
Even four-fold should be stable on
almost everything, but we'll keep eight.
Where their stupid hypers?
Where they put their stupid hypers? Come
on. Here. Oh.
Oh, here it is. So,
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Batch
size, batch length
you are using
Honestly, that's the reason this paper
is wrong. So, the whole reason that this
paper I consider this paper uh this
paper terrible science and why I wasted
so much time on the ablations,
they came up with all these clever
tricks, right? And they say, "Look,
these clever tricks make our method
super robust and stable."
But what happened is they threw the
clever tricks on reinforce instead of a
real algorithm. So when you have even a
good implementation of an incredibly
weak baseline algorithm like anything
that you will do will give you a
performance improvement
like that is not meaningful
and then if you actually try to throw
those tricks on PO like we did it turns
out they do nothing.
So that is the uh the main problem I
have with this paper.
I've never said that the result is
[ __ ] right?
I've gone as far as saying that this
paper is like borderline scientific
fraud, but like I I want to be very
clear about what I mean by that. But I
don't mean that the results are faked or
there's like actually malicious
anything. I mean it's just like
egregiously bad scientific practice.
And I'm being very harsh on it because
um you know these are experienced
researchers who should know better. I
would never do that if it were like
undergrads, right?
But the result of this has been that
I've seen tons of people like trying to
chuck chuck all these fancy tricks on
their stuff thinking that they do stuff
and like a lot of people have wasted a
lot of time as a result.
course, if this architecture uh ends up
actually being the thing that makes
sample f finally work, I think we'll be
able to look past that.
But like the slip in this paper, the
thing that made it wrong, it got past me
and the other authors of that the NERP
paper um which is like world class RL
researchers, right? It got by all of us.
We didn't realize until we'd already run
like so many experiments why it was the
case.
They do that to train the sequence
model.
Probably do.
I mean, we can compensate just by making
it 64 by 16.
Okay, that's 10:24
So presumably
they roll these out for 16 steps and
then they run
however many updates.
They run however many updates.
sampled from this.
I guess it's how long this thing stays
around for.
Yeah, it's just how long this sticks
around for because this is only a
thousand and this is freaking 5 million.
Okay, that's actually kind of a problem
for us, isn't it?
Yeah. So this is not
not a lot of segments.
doubt that that makes a big difference.
We'll say actually let's also do
we only need eight get most of the
benefit.
I mean you see it learns.
It's just it's very unstable. You see
how it like keeps crashing back down
like this.
Okay. Okay. And then we get the dynamics
losses.
Was off to me.
Why is this so low?
I didn't know what you were doing still.
I see.
Um, well, it depends if you have an RL
background or not, right? So, I'm doing
I'm basically trying to get this
paper with ridiculously good results,
but really really janky science and
really bad reference code uh to work in
Puffer Lib, which is like
really simple but really really high
performance and stable with good solid
reference code.
And the result of this should be that we
have a ridiculously good algorithm
working ridiculously stably with very
simple code. And then we kind of just
have the field in a really really good
spot. If I can do that, that'd be a
massive contribution to the field.
You know, I'm actually here
the logits.
still quite a bit of jank.
Is it better?
It's faster. I don't know if it's
actually better.
You still get this ridiculous crash the
entire policy thing right there. And it
recovers.
Couldn't get the SSM to work on anything
but cartpole.
100 down 100%. I mean, I will take a
look at it for sure.
We have right here. This is an RSSM,
right? like you see.
So, I'm trying to make it work.
I don't know how the formulation
compares to this. Do you understand the
KO losses involved with this thing?
Cuz I can't figure out right now. You're
supposed to clip these KO losses at one,
right? So like anything below one
doesn't matter, but they never get
anywhere near one.
I think I'm doing this right. You know
it's
this with detached target versus that
with detached target batch mean
reduction log on targets
just log softmax
of the uh the pre-sample logs.
You can just see how unstable this thing
is, right? Like it learns. It's just
super unstable.
I'm trying to figure out what I've
screwed up,
better at least.
Still screwy.
Why don't you use VS Code? Cuz I have
and this is better.
Oh, well, this just takes forever to
even record stats, right?
We'll have to try it on a different
thing after this. I should be able to
have the cart pull stable.
so fiddly.
Did I say
I mean, we had replay. This helped
tuning. I haven't really tuned it.
Compute. We already fixed this.
Wait, we fixed.
Do we need to make the just the policies
bigger?
There's no way, right? It's freaking
cartpole.
The dynamics loss being weird is still
the most suspicious thing to me.
Is it supposed to not be a batch mean or
a batch batched mean?
No, that would make it that'd push even
in the worst direction, right?
get a version where I'm looking for the
car. Yeah, go ahead.
Uh oh, hang on.
So, it's in like on on Paul WM or
whatever that branch. I mean, I can kind
of just show you.
So, here, right?
The idea is you have your encoder
function that takes in the hidden state
as well as the real observations. Okay.
And then you have your dynamics function
that only gets access to the hidden
state. It doesn't get access to ground
truth uh ground truth observation.
And this thing these both produce you
logits.
This sample function gives you this
codebook type thing where in my case
you're doing 16 categoricals of length
16 each. The dreamer uh bigger
architectures 32 by 32.
So this gives you this vector. you
flatten it and then your reward terminal
and reconstruction losses are based on
both the hidden state and the flattened
stochastic part which is just the
flattened stochastic uh the categoricals
right and then the KL I think I've done
this correctly is you just take these
loggets
right between the encoder and the
dynamics
and you do a KL div one detach the other
and the other one detach the first one
And according to the paper, they clamp
these losses so that they don't actually
get optimized to below one.
And I'm never seeing these get anywhere
near one. So if I clamp them, you don't
learn anything at all. But I'm trying to
figure out why my scale is so completely
different from theirs.
if that does anything.
Somebody fix the graphics for this
thing.
I'm trying to think what other what
other thing I could have missed.
Is there anything else that would affect
this?
Three gnats.
different distributions leading to high
KL. That's what I would think, right?
It should be that you get like a high KL
because they're completely different
distributions, right?
The other thing I'm not understanding is
I guess what portion forces you to rely
on the stochastic
not clamping adaptive gating?
Why? Because I mix between LSTM and SM.
I'm trying to figure out where where do
you even have to rely on
It's that you're supposed to get a
gradient here, right?
So, these reward terminal and
reconstruction
losses
Yeah. Reward terminal reconstruction.
These are supposed to get optimized here
which goes through Z, right? It goes
through the sampling with a straight
through estimate.
How does this make sense actually? Wait.
So,
dynamics and representation loss.
Have I done this correctly?
Doesn't seem right.
Maybe I've done something just stupid.
Hang on.
But then you have this prediction here.
This is a decoder.
Wait, so
something's screwy.
How are you actually training this
thing?
Am I missing something? Like, is this
really how the full thing is trained?
How does this make any sense?
Cuz you're training these two things to
match each other.
But then like
I guess it's through this. It's through
the decoder.
It's through this decoder loss. I
suppose
adaptive scaling rather than clamping.
H
I guess the question I have is why is if
they say that they're clamping to one,
why am I not seeing values in remotely
that range?
A reconstruction loss here, right?
Reconstruction loss. All OBS from MB
OBS.
So
all OBS X
yeah you're reconstructing through the
sampled
the sampled Z right
and H alone does not contain that
information right
unless I've done it wrong X.
Yeah. So, this doesn't take an X. Right.
This takes an X.
This doesn't take an X. So,
the only thing that you can do is you
have to learn through this Z, right?
Z logs.
Yeah. So, this is why the uh
reconstruction loss is supposed to work.
And we actually have a very low
reconstruction loss, right?
Saying that the max value is one. I
don't think so.
If you take a max of one and this, it's
the other way around. This says that if
the value is uh less than one, you don't
optimize it.
It would be a min otherwise, wouldn't
it?
or maybe I wait, do I have this
backwards? I don't think I do. The loss
is the max.
Yeah, right. like it's a max between one
and this value. So if the value is
bigger than one, you're going to get
that value, right? If the value is less
than one, you're going to get one which
has no gradient.
Yeah. But then so Carlos, the question
is why the heck am I not seeing values
of that scale at all? Like ever? Like
have I done something wrong? because I'm
not getting this.
Maybe this is the problem. Maybe it's
not right. I'm trying to figure out why
this is unstable. That's the key thing.
Like I have this. It can solve the
environment, but it's like super
unstable.
It should be clipped to one if less than
one. Wait, it should be clipped to one
if less than one.
What? What did you just type? If less
than one equal to one greater than equal
to value.
I think this is saying you can literally
write this as a max right between one
and this value. So if the value is
greater than one you optimize it. If
it's less than one you don't optimize
it.
And that matches the text as well.
Clipping dynamics and representation
losses below a value of one. This
disables them while they're already
minimized well to focus on learning the
prediction loss.
And I guess the one thing I didn't try
here.
Wait, you're not supposed to get
negative KL, right?
What do you mean you want an initial
baseline?
Yeah. Okay. Kale's freaking negative, so
that's bad.
Have I done this?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
If I do
It's still producing negative values.
All right.
floating point precision with small
probs seems unlikely, right?
what's like the maximum KL? It gets
arbitrarily big, doesn't it?
Yeah, it gets arbitrarily big.
right. So, I mean, this works roughly
like before, right?
Still super unstable.
that doesn't even make sense, right?
You know, that doesn't make sense. It's
got to be this way.
reconstruction loss.
You can minimize it pretty dang
strongly, right?
Well, no. We don't want to do zero here.
We want to do it
Oh yeah, they blow up.
Yeah, if you don't minimize them, they
blow up.
and at least so far this completely
destroys all learning.
Right. Like it just doesn't learn.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so this actually does work now.
It's still unstable, though. So, we
figured this one thing out,
but it's still super unstable.
Hey, boxing, we're doing world model
stuff.
All right, so this was not the uh the
solution to stability,
but at least we know that now.
And the reconstruction loss is quite
good.
All the other things, they're actually
quite good. Value loss is the one that's
still bad.
Interesting enough.
Weird mix to make the kale weld behaved.
You know, we are actually seeing
ridiculously low entropy here.
We could try that mix technique,
but like
they have an ablation that all those
tricks don't do all that much. And we
know also independently that they're
kind of just crap.
No, KL spikes would be the opposite.
Actually,
the KL would be this going to infinity
and nanning everything out.
This entropy is in the policy, not the
uh this. So, that's not it.
But at least we have this one thing
sorted now.
Okay, this trick we know is [ __ ]
So, we don't even have to look at this
one.
Uh, we also know that too hot is
[ __ ] so we don't have to really
care about that one.
What's the state of things? Uh, we have
something that's training sort of on
cartpole, but we're having stability
issues.
I'm The goal is to get like cart pole to
be sane and stable and then we throw it
on harder problems.
I'm using a replay ratio of eight
because this is
would model scale just screw with it
somehow.
If anybody wants to help me check for
like bad um like there might be spots
where they're detached gradients that
I'm not realizing.
Cherry chick uh cherry pick. Um
so
it's not that they're literally running
their final thing a thousand times and
picking the the time it works or
whatever. it's that they they're
basically cherrypicking a bunch of
really fiddly non-geneneralizable
techniques. So that like
the method is not going to be robust as
is presented here. That is very
expected. But the thing is puffer is not
cherrypicked like puffer lib is
ludicrously stable. It's a very very
good library and I'm using this as the
base. You know we have that optimizer
that batch scale that like setup for
everything.
So, my hope is to combine Puffer's
actual real stability with the sample
efficiency that this thing can
technically get.
I mean, they're all the other thing
standing out is their model sizes are
massive, but like it's freaking
cartpole, right?
They show scaling, but it's stable on
any of them, right? The only one that's
not stable is when they have a really
low replay ratio. And even that, it's
stable. It's just like not
[Music]
right, there's a restroom. I'll be back
in a second.
And then uh we're going to look for
gradient bugs.
Yeah, I know. 12 million parameters is
silly. You definitely don't need 12
million parameters for cartpull, right?
Reward and value grads.
I mean, no.
Yeah, no reward and value and no Greek.
Okay, this is fine.
We should probably figure out this
section of the code here, right?
This definitely breaks it, which is
really freaking weird, right?
Uh because it should be the target of
the value function, right?
You're training a value function to
match a target.
So something is weird that that doesn't
Dark
part of the loss.
Yeah. But look at this, right?
New value minus MB returns. MB returns
is advantage plus MB values.
See how it's weird.
confused about the mini batches. You
batch in the M dimensions, right? But
then the loop you don't use the index
batch is training.
this is a sample over the total segments
that we have in the replay buffer. So
there are number of segments with 16
steps each
and we pick a mini batch as a random
selection of those.
You training the actor and the value
here, right?
We definitely have something screwy here
for sure.
It should be
hatch, right?
Uh
kind of
the reason to use random and impuffer
use multimodal sampling. Yeah, cuz I'm
just trying to do something simple
first.
Um,
I'm trying to do something simpler first
and I don't think it's going to matter
as much because the world model training
is supervised.
Like if anything, I think what's going
to happen is I'm going to end up I'm
going to end up applying uh advantage
filtering to the outputs of the world
model itself. Like the hallucinated
experience is my guess.
You have insane spikes in value
function. Yeah, I know.
But like why? What's happening,
like value functions getting screwed up.
And it's weird because it's specifically
when I don't uh when I detach the
returns which should be like standard
you get here this is new value all new
value
like this
and then we do MB return it's going to
be advantage plus values like Yes.
I don't think this is going to help,
right?
Where is it?
In the original code,
MB values comes from the buffer. So this
doesn't have a gradient, right? So this
has no gradient.
And we have a clipped formulation here.
But this is off policy clipping
which is different, right? Because new
value equals NB value if it's on policy.
So this is zero. So this is the same as
new value. So this term is the same as
this term. So this max doesn't exist.
And it's literally just like the loss
unclipped 0.5 mean.
at least clamp it that way if I'm going
to try to clamp.
See if it does anything.
I don't think so, but at least give it a
shot.
It's so screwy. And if I just don't
detach it. Works, right?
So, let's see what this does with the
clamping.
Not stable.
Brains, but it's not stable.
It's like way better at least, right?
Like even with uh with the clamping,
but it's still not stable.
the problem.
Go check costas.
We're not going crazy.
Well, this should tell me something.
Screwy, right? Like this should tell me
something is very weird.
This doesn't work.
Oh, that makes sense. Either way,
I just totally screwed up the advantage
estimate. Maybe
fine.
Yeah, I'm a lambda.
I just want to be sure that there's not
some garbage thing weird going on.
Okay, good. So, it's at least symmetric,
right?
I mean, we know that I'm confused when I
start pasting [ __ ] into Grock because we
know that that's never going to freaking
work. But
advantages need to be detached.
It shouldn't need to be. That function
doesn't define gradients. I mean, I'll
try it. I'm pretty sure
I can do this by detaching the returns,
right? Like this
and then we can do attach here.
All right, let's we'll try that.
Yeah, that's the problem though, Jess.
They're all so bad that they all just
waste my time anyways. So like it's
never productive when I paste that in
like stuff in like that almost ever
anyways.
I kind of don't care about like hopping
between language models every other
month when like lab releases latest
model, right?
Yeah. So, as you can see, this still
does not work.
performs on coding test does it
with the new models? I don't know.
I honestly don't trust all the people
evaluating the different coding models
like cuz the people who are using these
coding models very heavily are kind of
terrible programmers anyways for the
most part.
Great. No, I never did that. That's what
I told Yakine is that if you wanted to
do um if you wanted to do like pixels
training and have it be at at least a
reasonable speed, that's how you would
do it.
That's what I told him.
Yeah. So, this is just doing stupid
stuff.
Benchmark is not great as far as LM
solving problems above my grade. Yeah.
Well, I mean this is not a programming
problem, right? This is an algorithm
problem.
into the debugger. Debugger really
doesn't do much here again because it's
an algorithm problem, right?
Let's see. Is this doing anything? No,
this is just like
Well, we do need to figure out why this
is happening.
It means it makes a completely different
target, right?
to make a completely different target
or not.
I actually don't know what that does.
It's like thing equals thing plus
constant.
Maybe that's actually fine.
But why does it make such a huge
difference? That's like weird, right?
Not just this, right? Not just like a
basic scaling issue.
The value function is blown up.
Other losses are reasonable as well.
detach
according to this and we should detach
I don't think this is we tried this
we actually tried this All right.
Is that Is that letting it cheat in some
way? I'm not understanding.
What if I just detach
attach this?
Oh,
is this um
okay? No, this kind of works maybe.
Okay, now this does work.
Pretty unstable.
Does work though.
Is it just really unstable? Is that
what's happening?
I want to see it like actually
Oh, entropy is zero.
Hang on. Entropy is zero.
How's this happen?
Oh, yeah. It just straight zeros
entropy.
It's like zeroing out the
entropy completely.
Well, it stopped zeroing out entropy.
I just can't learn a good policy, right?
Yeah, it should be detached boxing. I
forgot to do that because normally it's
computed from previous data, so it's not
a problem.
Well, actually now it is kind of
learning some stuff, but it's like even
less stable than before,
right? Like this is crazy how unstable
this thing is. I have them both detached
now.
It hasn't done me any favors.
I mean, I guess it is like it trains and
then it crashes all the way back down.
It's bizarro,
I'd be surprised if that's all it is,
bet. I mean, I've tried this several
times in different versions of this, and
it seems like there is this actual weird
cyclic behavior regardless of what you
do.
advantage come from the world model. The
value comes from the world model and the
value is going to predict the uh the
return which is value uh plus advantage,
right?
I think that this just totally made this
[ __ ] up is my guess here.
Well, I can tell you Grock is completely
wrong as expected. Don't trust language
models. They're stupid.
Um
because literally the fact that they use
um a bend value function makes it
impossible for it to still be attached.
The only thing I could potentially do
here,
right, would be
I'm basically just wondering if the
learning rate for the critic has to be
way slower.
Thank you, bet. Yes, please do start the
uh the repository, folks. It helps me
out a ton. It's free.
Yeah. So, this does not make a huge
difference it seems.
Fact the value loss just like blows up
so much like that.
Why would the value loss
appreciate the puffer support boxing.
Yeah, it's like, all right, welcome to
this new website. First thing you got to
do is start this puffer.
The puffer a star. Just how it works on
GitHub.
details are there that I haven't deal
dealt with yet.
thinking maybe it's the RL just moving
too fast for the world model, but no, it
doesn't seem like it.
Yeah, this just doesn't do anything. And
it's the entropy is zero still, which is
ridiculous. Why are we on zero entropy?
That stuff is weird. The detached stuff
is weird because like you should never
have attached targets.
Like that doesn't make sense. You're
basically just predicting yourself
otherwise. Like you're predicting your
own output.
I don't think you do need the gradients
to flow through returns and advantage.
Advantage is basically just like a
priority waiting. The real gradient
comes from negative log prop, right?
I mean it's like
And the fact that this does work. If I
just do this.
I had it more stable earlier today
arguably right
Well, that's just an entropy
coefficient. You can do that, but the
thing is I already have one and it
shouldn't be pushing entropy to zero
immediately.
And if you see here, it's not doing
that, right? Like in this case, it's not
like there is reasonable entropy
present,
but for some reason, right, there's this
huge difference.
If I just make the uh if I detach the
targets like this, which is what you
should do, the target should be detached
as far as I can tell, right? It just
doesn't learn anything. I have no idea
why.
world model has its own. No, the uh the
critic is learned only through
uh the imagined data. There's no value
function learning happening from
supervised data. That would be off
policy.
like completely off policy as well.
I mean, you can see it's like trying
here, right? It's like
it's bouncing around at least.
Hey Satcha. Uh, more successful I'd say.
We have I mean we have something
actually running at least. Okay, so it
is actually
kind of doing something here.
Let's go look for different bugs.
We're just expecting this to update in
place, right?
Which the value function RL?
The value function is learned through
RL.
The value that is part of the RL right
now. It wouldn't work without it. Satcha
right
critic has learned end to end as part of
the hallucinated experience bit.
Yeah. So state gets updated
in place, right?
is distribution to approximate. Yeah. So
Z is a sample. I'll show you.
Okay. So here's sample Z. You get Z
logits which is just 16.
Okay. Okay. And then we take
we take soft max of the lodges to get
probs. And then we take 16 samples of
the 16 dim categorical.
And we make a one hot.
And then we return the one hot
with the straight through estimate like
this.
Does that make sense?
And like it runs
not doing super well.
Nice as a baseline. Yeah, well, it's not
doing very well. And like, oddly, it was
doing better when I had bugs in it.
Like, it was doing better when I had if
you It does way better, for instance, if
you don't detach the returns. you do
like um you know value equals advantage
plus uh values. If you don't detach the
value target, it does substantially
better. It's still super noisy though.
Like I've seen it solve very very
quickly, even impressively quickly. But
the uh the policy is very unstable and
it like just crashes back to random.
There are additional tricks. I know for
a fact that some of those tricks do
nothing. Um there are others that
possibly I might need. But the thing is
like
this should just work for cartpole
without him because they're all
relatively minor except KL balance is
like kind of relevant.
Yeah. So, that one I have basically
complete proof is [ __ ]
So that's like a fancy thing that they
added that actually doesn't do anything.
which is one of the reasons I don't like
this paper as a scientific contribution
because half of it's wrong.
But like it's just pushed entropy to
zero here for no apparent reason, right?
Pedagorical add uni mix.
Do they have an ablation on that?
I guess they don't have an ablation on
that. So, I can try that.
How do you um how do you implement that
Satcha? Is that just uniform added
before you compute
sample or what?
Something went together
all the tricks. Um not really.
not uh not doing sim log on the rewards
is like if you just clip it's very close
and then like a few of these don't
really do anything. Kale balance is I
think the only one that's kind of fine.
I don't understand what this thing is
doing, though. Like,
Like, here, I'll show you something
weird.
You want to see something real weird?
If I literally just get rid of this
detach.
If I don't detach the return, which is
like clearly wrong.
It learns like way better
with the returns not uh with the returns
attached.
Isn't that weird?
And the thing is it's still like
it's still super janky.
Like you see it almost had the task
solved and it like oscillates around a
whole bunch.
See, like that's almost solved
and it just like is super unstable
if you don't detach.
Exactly. So like it should be worse,
right? So why is it that it works so
much better with it attached?
Um
so we have the
typically we will normalize the uh the
rewards not the returns.
So the returns are sort of bounded.
They're bounded because the rewards are
bounded.
I mean, I suppose I could normalize the
returns as well.
Okay, maybe better.
I think it's still super unstable,
right?
I mean that's better for detached
though.
That is substantially better
at least for the detached version
normalization. Yeah, it's forgive me
when it's it's difficult to actually
trust their tricks when like I literally
have 20,000 hours of aund ablations. Um
basically saying that the science in
this whole paper sucks.
You definitely don't need quantile
return normalization. Like there's no
reason you should need that.
You can see how unstable this thing is
though, right?
On what should be a very easy problem as
well.
Let me see what happens if I get rid of
this um
clipping. thing.
which I mean is so obnoxious because
it's presented as like, you know, the
stable algorithm from God in the paper.
I wouldn't be surprised Oh,
Well, this trick,
this trick here
We just like hyper prim sweep everything
at this point or is there like still
core stuff
missing?
with the value normalization.
Copy core hypers. It's tough to copy
core hypers because he has like the
slowest stupidest thing ever.
I have all the batch sizes multiplied by
like a fixed big value.
I'm not trying to match it in samples
initially. I'm just trying to get
something stable. And larger batches
should, if anything, make it way more
stable. I've copied like some ratios
though, as best as I could.
We're doing um
we've got like mini batches of 32K
steps.
We're doing eight updates. So, eight
updates,
eight separate mini batches. We're
collecting the same like 32k mini batch
from the environment at a time. Got a
nice big buffer, so it should be a
pretty slow moving. Um, the data change
should be pretty slow moving.
And this is like way closer. Maybe I
should look at this thing.
Is this from the original? Wait. Losses
provided as
I didn't see this in the paper. Where is
that?
Well, to be fair, Satcha, if um if I get
this working very nicely in puffer and
like we actually have a clean way to
trade off between compute and sample f
uh one on the open source side, this
basically fixes the one big remaining
thing in the whole field. And uh on the
other hand, right, like I can directly
leverage that to go sign contracts to
help me fund all this work like very
very easily because I've had several
very large companies ask me for um like
that sort of a trade-off.
So it's both like this directly goes to
enhance the science uh and all the open
source stuff we're doing, but also helps
me on the company as well.
Yeah, this seems very poorly controlled
to me. Honestly,
this seems like Yeah, this is very
poorly controlled.
Is there a huge difference actually?
Hang on. Let me see if that made a huge
difference just normalizing the
uh the values the value target.
Go to PhD advisor found topic designing
good and stable recipe for multi-agent
world model.
Uh I don't think anything changes
because it's multi- aent Satcha. I don't
think anything changes.
Just that you need slightly fresher
data.
Interesting. So, that actually seems to
have made a uh a pretty substantial
difference.
It's just like so ridiculously unstable,
right?
Okay. Well, that's there's definitely a
difference then.
I should probably run this, commit this
if it's stable, and then keep going from
here.
I'll be right back. Model will probably
stay unstable unless you handcraft these
update ratios.
What do you mean handcraft the update
ratios?
But do you have any idea why it's
unstable?
Like a normal RL was very unstable
before I did puffer. Right.
Well, I'm sweeping some of the hypers
here or attempting to. We'll see if it
finds anything or not. You know, oddly
enough, like the sweeps I've run so far
have found like nothing. It's really
odd. They've actually just found
nothing.
I will be right back though. Give me a
minute and then I will I'm going to
think about what we do next on this to
make this like actually
reasonably feasible, right?
Maybe experiment with fusion latent. You
could do that.
Am I understanding the training process
correctly?
I suppose
this shouldn't matter that much, right?
Sampling from
Yeah. Right. But like, so are they
they're sampling a certain number of of
trajectory segments, right?
And then they're training the world
model on those segments, but then
they're also generating a certain amount
of experience.
So, are they training the world model on
the same amount of imagined segments as
they're training the um are they
training the actor on the same number of
imagined segments as they're training
the world model on a number of real
segments? That make sense?
Yeah, exactly. So, I I don't see it
anywhere in here, but
Yeah. So this is stop grab on advantage
here,
right?
then from sampled segments. Yeah, that's
what we're doing.
Yo, Satcha, they don't have a stop grat
on this. Is this just an oversight
though? Or
why the heck is this a log a log loss on
um
Oh, because they have it bucketed,
right?
Yeah. So then if they have it bucketed,
it's impossible that the targets have
grads, right?
Does it actually wait
that I don't think it even makes sense
to do this value norm does it?
Even though it's like working
empirically, does it even make sense to
have this norm here?
You can't just normalize the returns
like that, right? Because then the value
no longer has the uh the same meaning.
Am I wrong here? Like you just you can't
do this, right?
like you could do a fixed scale, I
guess.
I mean, how the heck is it the case that
it it trains on the thing that makes no
bloody sense? It doesn't train on the
thing that should work.
I mean, I guess it sort of does train,
right?
Maybe if you replace one Gian.
Didn't they say that was worse?
the entropy and the value that are like
bouncing all over the place.
Be fair, this actually is learning if
you just give it time. It's just very
unstable.
It was, but it worked as well. I mean, I
might do that as an ablation, right?
This should not be the thing. You'd
agree though there shouldn't be the
thing that's completely destabilizing
it.
Like why does it do this thing right
where it just dips a ton and then it
like shoots back up
right? Isn't it weird how it's like
oscilly?
Presumably, you'd want more fresh data.
It should make it easier. No,
the problem is Dreamer is just like
stupidly stupidly slow. Like, we're not
going to wait 3 hours per experiment
every time I need to run cartpole,
right?
They literally will spend three hours
per experiment on Atari 100K.
zero entropy. You see
zero entropy on the policy
well that's the purpose of it but having
fresh data makes it easier
because your initial data is going to
suck because your policy sucks
how it affects the convergence.
I'm gonna have to just spend more
compute, meaning I'm going to be sitting
here waiting just all day while I'm
running these dumb experiments.
Like if you actually go to the dreamer
um if you actually use like their batch
sizes and stuff, you're going to be
running your GPU at 5% utilization.
Yeah. So this here is
I mean it's a zero entropy policy,
right?
How does this happen?
Constant oscillations.
Well, do we know why why it does that? I
mean, so far on breakout, it just
doesn't work, right? It's just entropy
crashed to zero.
Maybe that's a clue for us
is that the um
is that this revolves around entropy
crashing.
Yeah, like it's instantly set entropy to
zero. Okay, well that's stupid, right?
Why does it have entropy set to zero?
That's not the entropy of KL, right?
That's the entropy of the policy.
That's not like KL spike. That's the
policy.
No, that's not diverged. Diverged would
be the losses explode and it nanss out.
Right? This is it's just decided to
optimize um it's decided to determinize
the policy
the opposite of diverged
like collapse to um fix policy on this
stupid thing
accidentally The disc setting discrete
to continues.
What do you mean setting discrete to
continues
passing all logit? So you get Z samples
here.
Well, our RL is generally pretty good.
It's puffer lip satcha.
Okay. So, there's your your multih hot Z
thing,
and there's your initial H, which is
going to be the same for everything, of
course, because it's just the initial
zero state.
and then you're passing the sampled
version, right? We're passing the
samples here
and then you sample
from your log jets. That's
going to detach rewards and terminals
cuz they are getting trained supervised.
Greet path wasn't returning logits
tensors.
Greet path.
Um,
but this sample is only supposed to give
you
Wait,
are you supposed to be using both of
them?
No, you're not right. You're not
supposed to give it the logits.
So the sample comes from the logits,
right? So the logits is deterministic.
You're not supposed to give this the
logits. You're only supposed to give it
the sample, right? The sample and then
the um like the GRU state or whatever,
right?
See, I'm pretty damn sure I've done this
right.
So ZT is a sample,
right?
I just need way more entropy.
Wouldn't make sense to me.
It crashes down constant.
The value loss like spikes up.
I mean, it's more consistently cycling
now so that it's not just like
collapsing.
It does. No, there's no way it's managed
to collapse entropy with a bonus that
high.
That's crazy.
and has a very low reconstruction loss.
That's ridiculous.
Oh, fine.
Well, that's like entropy is usually
like 0.01 at the most,
right?
So, it's ridiculous that you need to
even do this
in the world model is getting
getting its data
I mean you can see right like if the
world model is collapsed
I'd have to be do something like
massively stupid. No,
I'm actually curious what happens if I
do this at this point,
which is to say um
constrain it to the actual
onaul data.
Like that's supposed to be massively
easier, but look at the entropy.
value function is really sensitive to
scale.
It's still not great, but that's like
workable, right?
crash
still.
It's doing something different though
than you'd expect because
Wonder if there's some sort of clipping
analog you need for this.
And so never actually full solve the
problem
but substantially better and
non-determinized policy.
If I do
I do this
just need the value loss to be
normalized.
Um, they're obnoxious. They work
sometimes, but they're very obnoxious
happening.
Okay. No. So, it is something screwy it
seems with the targets.
Oh, no. There it goes.
I mean, at least this is like more
correct, right?
This you're actually allowed to do.
Doesn't mess with the returns.
I mean, you're getting cyclical
performance all the way up to solving
it.
well, it can't be the world model doing
that, right?
Can you screw up the world model with
the actor?
I assume this doesn't just fix it,
Right?
Not just as simple as them being
slightly off balance, right?
This actually fully crashes at
zero entropy.
Yeah,
I there are no production grade
implementations of any of this crap for
uh anyone wondering. It's like all
[ __ ]
production grade just means your code
sucks honestly
most of the time like if you're going by
what it like the actual code whenever
anyone says that it just means your code
sucks
This one. This is the only thing I was
looking for, which is I I like already
kind of thought that I'd missed.
Let me go find the existing reference
and see if I can see where they detach a
gradient.
10 training FPS.
That's hilarious.
All right, so they stuck a giant ass
transformer in and it's actually like
not a big difference. So, it actually
does kind of make sense that you could
go transformer based with um
it does kind of make sense you could go
transformer-based
with the world model cuz you actually
get some parameter scaling it seems.
But yeah, this is not necessarily I'd
probably look at search before that.
Okay, so here's your dynamics thing,
right?
Do they have this in the paper
somewhere?
The stop grad
If the actor is not going to
back prop into
the world model
you basically would have to detach both
of these, wouldn't you?
Does that do it? I don't think that'll
work, right?
That actually does. Well, we'll see if
it's stable.
Is this what it's supposed to be? So
it's like, hey, don't back prop through
the world model.
It's still not as stable as you would
expect it to be. And this is a
relatively like well a very simple
problem as well.
You see, it's like the crashing thing is
still
still a problem.
They do have separate
separate learning rates here.
Um, let me try scaling the actions real
quick.
This is this still stable now if I do it
this way
or no.
Okay, that's actually still stable
enough.
Try like 0.2. E.
So screwy.
What are all these damn papers coming
from? Oh, you know what? These are all
these are like kind of random.
Yeah, these are like super random.
I think a lot of this stuff is kind of
just people like boot like um
just jumping on the popular thing
because it got published recently in
nature. Okay. Um
I wonder if now I can stop with the uh
the V-lo scale
cuz this thing was janky, right?
What can I do this now?
Okay, it's still not going to be fully
stable is my guess,
but that's like marketkedly better right
now. We'll see if it even finishes at
that level of perf or if it collapses
back more permanently. But
at the very least, that's like
marketkedly better.
Don't need any of this return scaling.
That doesn't make any bloody sense. Get
rid of that.
Now the question is why is it collapsed
like at all?
This tunable.
We might just be able to tune some loss
coefficients actually.
It's working like this.
But cartpole is still a super trivial
problem.
Do we see anything on breakout yet?
The result of this
Zero entropy on breakout instantly.
Instantly zero entropy. Huh?
And yeah, it's very easy to learn a
world model on nothing, right?
Complete collapse.
Yeah, this is still not better than um I
mean this is still a trivial.
You need to get like eight or whatever
and then it's non-trivial.
I just like add some entropy and have
this thing
Too big or too small? It's definitely
not too small.
Larger batch size should just be better
if I can keep up with it, which I can
here.
This is like some specific quirk, I
think, cuz entropy loss should
definitely not be zero.
I wonder if it's just like not getting
added somehow.
This has got to just be way too high,
right?
Yeah. I think that it's just like the
collapsing problem.
Why is it so difficult to get this thing
to do like anything? My gosh.
This is the like only non-trivial task.
I mean, the first non-trivial task that
you would try to get it to
Thanks for your expost. Learned a lot.
Comfortable with Python, C and Java,
learning Go recently. What's your take
on reading learning go book?
unique features of program I have to
prioritize. Uh I have not ever written
any go. I'm uh generally puffer
everything is Python and C.
All the environment stuff is in C.
Neural net stuff is in Python. Go seems
fine. Uh if you know a few other
languages though I don't I don't know
why you would have a language specific
book ever. Just like build stuff and
reference the docs pretty much.
Well, I I can't expect it to even do
anything with this entropy coefficient
being this ridiculous, right?
Get rid of this bot.
Going to replace Java with Go.
Um,
well, hopefully the Go code doesn't look
anything like the Java code, right?
I know. Java is just like a Java is a
language where like literally at the
language level, it prevents you from
writing good code. Like you actually
cannot write good code in Java.
It's just impossible.
There not that many languages that do
that, but Java is one of them.
Oh yeah, I had to learn Java in 20 not
2008. When was it?
Like 2010ish maybe.
It actually poisons you as a programmer.
It takes years to unlearn Java.
Okay. Well, at least I have this thing
like kind of stable.
But it's not doing anything.
That's not great.
How to unlearn Java quickly. Write more
C.
just like I mean honestly look at some
of the puffer environments. It's just
really simple procedural C and then you
realize oh this would be 10,000 lines of
code and a 10,000th of the speed in
Java. That's a completely stupid
language. Why would anybody ever write
code that way? And then you've unlearned
Java.
There you go.
Yeah, at a lot of companies you're just
not going to be able to get away from
C++ unfortunately.
But yeah, if you can get away from it,
definitely worth getting away from it.
well to be fair I mean I suppose
cartpole is such a weak baseline that
getting something to work on that really
isn't indicative of anything else.
honestly could be worse. Like
it's used like embedded into a few
different gamedev things. Like Unity
uses C, right?
It's still so weird to see that this
gets solved.
Like you get a good policy on this so
reasonably. It's super unstable, right?
But then you don't even see it go over
random or like trivial policy perf once
on uh even something like breakout.
The engine required it. Yeah, it's
probably Unity you were doing, right?
Um
heck do we do about this though?
poll. We did drop the learning rate a
little bit.
Batch size. Batch size.
I'll do this. But there's no way this
makes the difference, right?
needing baseline breakout. Yeah. So the
thing is cartpole is just so easy. Like
literally anything will work on
cartpole.
any place for Transformers and RL. Yeah,
it's just that they're slow.
We'll probably do that at some point if
I can get something that's like at least
reasonable.
I'm trying to think where we go from
here. So, we have something that like
is decentish, like mostly does cartpole,
and it's just so incredibly unstable on
everything else.
Uh, 10 is above random if it keeps that
for more than like a data point or two.
the heck of it. Let's just make sure
it's not this stupid balancing thing I
hacked on.
It's like very close, but it's I know
it's just like going to one wall or
whatever.
It holds until training ends.
be sober for math on Saturday night.
Yeah.
So,
we can mess we can start messing with
model scale and stuff, but that really
what we're doing.
the reconstruction loss is like super
low as well.
I mean the RL on this should not be bad,
right?
I mean, this very much limits it
technically.
You see this,
but I think that like
screw up the world model even more if
you don't detach.
Adding noise always helps. Nah,
no way.
I guess
if we're going to use a benchmark, we
need a benchmark that we can actually
solve.
We may as well do this.
And then I suppose we can figure out the
stability issue on this.
Let's start going through a few
different options
instead of just sitting here like
thrashing. Right.
All right. So first one
stronger dynamics and representation
losses. Does that do anything?
just to make sure it's not
I don't think this is it for reference,
but we're kind of just going to go
through and exhaustively validate some
Enough.
Okay. So, this is the environment is
solved right here. And then it's going
to collapse,
Do you see how unstable that is? So,
it's not
because of this thing.
Let's make sure we'll get our baseline
be the replay buffer. Absolutely could
be.
Do you have ideas on what to do with
that though?
Uh actually it does seem that this does
something, right?
Okay. It actually seems like the uh the
clipping was the clipping too low.5
Okay. So, yeah, that's actually a big
difference. It's still unstable, but the
lower clip actually makes a difference.
It's still quite unstable, I would say.
So, next thing.
Do we go to the original codebook size
from the paper?
Now, that doesn't seem like a good
option. And it's still crashing pretty
bad. Look, it's at 100 there.
definitely should not be doing that.
Show us your socks.
No,
we're here for research, not for random
weird degeneracy.
You have samples.
And to be clear, I think is this this is
actually good that we're detaching here,
right? Or is it just like noise?
Okay. No, there's a huge huge
difference.
Like it still can learn, I think, but
there's a huge difference. Like the
gradients are fighting each other. I
already tried clipping even more.
that only works if the guy you're
talking to is actually ugly. My guy, I
know I look good.
How's breakout now? Uh, we can try it,
but I very much doubt any different.
Yeah. No.
So, um
I mean know our clue is right. It solves
the task and then is unstable
once solved.
Those
So, this thing here is not solving,
right?
Needs to go like at least to seven.
And you should basically be able to do
that instantly with a welltuned um well,
pretty much anything.
I'm actually curious if with the fixes
it's still wonky like if you just detach
don't detach returns if it's better.
I don't think this ever solved the
stability issue regardless though,
right?
Okay. It's also like at least now it's
like worse if you do something wrong. So
now at least we're directionally
correct.
That's kind of correct.
We try this loss thing with the new
scales.
Kale div
strengthening KL div penalty. Which KL
div penalty?
There's not a kale div penalty. There
kale losses of various types.
Okay. Well, this doesn't make a
difference here now.
It's just the uh the divergence.
Boss model optimizes up, model optimizes
down.
I wonder if this 01 rep loss thing is a
mess.
Have all these losses like totally
unscaled relative to each other is not
All right.
yeah, it's actually like jumping back up
to the top.
Okay, there's entropy.
I don't think it works without it
though, right?
Let's see if it works without entropy
now.
This will at least tell if it's it's
entropy loss causing the crash, which I
doubt it, but you know, it's possible
technically. So, we'll check it.
And no, it seems like it is not.
It's not entropy causing the uh the
crash.
Okay.
Is it the learning rate causing the
crash?
Okay. So,
does it maintain this?
That's the same sort of qualitative
crash down, right?
With a much lower learning rate.
You know what?
Let's try
Ask
things obnoxious.
W logic. Let's do that.
Even better.
Let's see what this does.
So, it's not coming from this being uh
sampling.
The instability is not coming from this
being sample like sample based
actually let's let's test the straight
through estimator. There.
Okay. So, without this
learning is way harder
as it should be.
You have no way to back prop through
this thing.
So if I do logs instead of props, what
happens?
We've ablated this a little bit. I'm
happy.
happy with this at least.
See?
So, these are all correct.
All H and then Z.
Fine.
You still have the instability problem,
right?
It really doesn't seem to be anything
blow uh blowing up, right?
None of the losses really are blowing up
at all.
the reconstruction loss that gives us a
better representation.
What other stuff have I not tried yet?
Like that's a lot of what I can do.
What this is supposed to do is set the
OBS to something new on terminal.
Not perfect, but that was way more
stable for a bit, right?
this is state
terminal is set to zero.
The terminal set to zero. Oh.
Okay, so this should now be correctly
resetting. Okay.
What other stability crap is there?
Like what else could we be uh missing?
Okay. So this is now
can change the imagination horizon right
Yeah, it's still it still collapses and
in about the same amount of time. It's
just that it's running slower.
So, it looks like it takes longer to
collapse, but it's actually just running
slower.
better though.
So it would seem I guess we'll let this
run for a bit and we'll see if it like
actually ultimately collapses to not
doesn't recover.
What the heck causes this type of a
thing? That's ridiculous.
multiple.
What?
That should not be the case. Bet.
Oh, yeah. That branch, the imitation.
There's that's something different
though. So I have it set up so that
you're imitating like one mini batch
exactly. So it's fully on Paul. There's
something different going on there.
Now we got this stupid thing stable,
man.
get this like the same qualitative trend
over and over again.
need 0.5 grade clip.
Is it just instability in the
optimizing?
I doubt that.
I guess of the numerical things though
it's the more likely
for pram but we definitely don't want to
go to a shittier optimizer right because
then we just expect to have this problem
but even more
How big is the replay buffer? Is it
holding enough? I think I made it like 4
million or something.
I mean, we are like we are going through
the replay buffer way faster than
Dreamer is, I suppose,
because we're doing like a ton of
samples.
I guess I could go try that.
network should definitely big enough.
It's freaking cartpole, right?
This actually has been slightly better.
Let me try one other thing which is
if I just like crank this that should do
something similar, right? You get more
updates on your data.
Now, the problem is it takes forever to
even figure out if this does crash,
The thing is like look, h 4,000 steps
per second. Yay. We're so good at
reinforcement learning.
Like [ __ ] parameters.
It's Is it going to be any more stable?
I doubt it. Let's see.
something about these big batch sizes
actually.
Let's see if this is stable. I'm
curious.
That is honestly way less stable than
before. like this,
and you have it solved in um
like 100k steps, right?
I just want to see
cuz that would just it would give me
information if this did something
[Music]
It's like close. It needs to actually
stay above seven for a little bit for me
to be confident.
Overfitting for cart pole since nothing
will break out. Now it's lower.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know. Bet. It's going to be
difficult to get a
new algorithm working
and like it just requires a lot of
testing and fiddling.
But this does actually like anything
above seven is above random. But we're
not really getting a ton of samples. But
if this thing stays above seven at any
point.
I'm pretty sure that there's something
wrong with
our large batching formulation applied
to Dreamer.
Yeah, look at that.
still solves
under 20 seconds.
Box at 1.0 perform it
from STM since I have a mixing case
paste.
Yeah, you can you can I mean PR it to a
new branch obviously,
but yeah, for sure.
I'll take a look at it.
It's actually kind of tough to tell
whether this is doing much.
Oh,
you also got to keep in mind the
estimates are way noisier because fewer
data points.
value loss.
Yeah, it's low though.
You should be able to get stable
consistent 200 right on a cart pull as
well. It shouldn't just recover fast or
whatever.
Go look and see how we can get that to
work.
I mean car. Wait, this is the wrong end.
Carpole's supposed to literally solve in
3 seconds. The other thing
It does seem that there is something to
do with the batch size though, right?
The thing is the replay buffer is so big
now that we have literally all the data
that we've collected from the whole
training right here.
Nowhere near as bad as with um
you know the the data buffer moving as
quick
but I mean it's still
like it's not even getting max score at
all anymore there.
This version especially should be super
stable.
Hey, James. I'm trying to get freaking
world models to be stable.
I think it's just these coefficients,
right?
I guess technically it could just be the
coefficients.
Seems wrong to me.
and it's still not good enough because
it doesn't do anything on breakout. So,
it's like close to perfectly solving the
trivial task, which is not
like that's not a super high bar.
This does like nothing on breakout,
right?
long. I know you're supposed to be able
to solve in like 100k frames or
something ridiculous.
Gamma lambda, right?
Did gamma lambda have any hope?
Just not at all. Right.
Literally just
[Music]
Oh yeah, I forgot Pong has like a really
obnoxious learning curve as well.
Not a great environment for quick tests
if you're not actually solving it.
But here, I'm pretty confident we're
just not either way, right?
[Music]
I mean,
Okay. Yeah, it's definitely better than
random.
Yeah, it's getting like one point or
whatever.
Usually Pong has a very aggressive
learning curve though where like when
you learn anything on it, you learn the
whole end very quickly.
Seems not to be working here.
I'm trying to remember. There were
definitely things where I couldn't get
it to do anything at all on Pong.
So progress, not a lot of progress, but
it's progress.
AI commit descriptions.
I don't have any AI
descriptions, right?
Oh, they like the platform added that as
a feature, I guess.
Okay. So, like unbelievably painfully
slow,
but this thing does learn a little bit
of pong.
I was hoping it would like start
learning fast and we'd actually get to
see it do something, but
at least we have like some confirmation
other than just cartpull.
That said, we probably should just do
Yes.
Okay,
There.
Wait, decision transformers offline,
isn't it?
Interesting that this doesn't just
instantly scale up.
I think that this should just scale up.
No.
19 million parameters on freaking
cartpole.
Behavioral cloning is very easy to get
to work. Actually, you can do that in an
hour if you just like there's even a
branch on it. It's really really easy.
I scaled this thing up and it supposedly
this is supposed to work better.
But presumably this is still not stable,
right? Yeah.
So, I mean, all we're accomplishing here
is making it [ __ ] slow and useless.
just as unstable as ever before,
if not even worse. Lovely.
So, I mean, it really should not be the
model scale of anything, right?
I just like it really shouldn't be.
Yeah, there's behavioral cloning branch.
The fact that I just lack a principled
way to even get this thing to work
better is bothersome. Um,
I I mean it shouldn't be
unless there's like some key fundamental
screw up,
which I guess is possible. It's like
carpull so easy. You can learn it even
if you've totally screwed something up.
I like Breakout. Well, breakout's too
hard at the moment because this
algorithm is too crap.
Let me just see make sure I fully
understand.
So annoying to like an all Saturday just
looking at this stupid paper.
Well, I'm also somewhat grumpy because
of that.
I've run I've been running at least a
10k six days a week, lifting five days a
week on like a,000 maybe even 1500
calorie average cut.
The representation lost back to its
original scale.
I really don't blame blame all my
colleagues who've left this field
though. Like
just the quality of the science in this
space is just so abysmal and the code is
just so ass. It's like a stupid cursed
field most of the time. Like literally
interact with any published paper and
it's just a stupid field.
Like I keep forgetting
like what a big deal the puffer trainer
is because I use it all the time and
it's like oh look at all these
publications is like oh you do so much
better than PO and they don't [ __ ]
work. None of them work. You go
implement them. You look online and
people like a few people got them to
work. It took him literally six months,
four to six months to implement one
paper
Takes you as long to like replicate a
paper as it took the author to make the
original paper. That's like no value.
SPL. I still don't understand why that
algorithm is supposed to work.
I tried off policy stuff, but it was
ass.
The paper lacks literally everything. I
have 20,000 hours of a of ablation
showing that like their reasoning for
half the paper is wrong as well.
Then where do you get Z from?
You do have prep Z, right?
Then you do you take Z, you take state,
you get previous action.
Do your end code
agent X you sample
actor and value use the sampled version
between old latent and the new latent
uh you don't have between old latent and
new latent but you do have between the
encoder and the dynamics function and
that's already being optimized Well,
this seems fine to me, right? You have
your states.
Here's your obs.
Get your previous action,
your previous Z, which both start off as
zero.
I have them zeroed up top, right? Yeah.
Then you have your previous
action.
doesn't matter. Literally the env isn't
even like the env has one neg one and
negative one rewards anyways.
or just I think it's just one
lstm. Let's see.
Okay. So on the first time step for the
like or actually on every time step you
get the real obscode
Z state previous action you update
previous action here
get logits from the encoder you get
hallucinated logits from dynamic you
sample the real logits not the
hallucinated ones
reward terminal it's straight through
gradient estimate on Z
reconstruction loss as Well,
end everything. Stack everything.
Reward loss is mean squared error. I
could take another look at these
offsets, but I'm pretty damn sure that
these are correct.
I mean, I could just do
I can do this, right? And I can check.
Pretty sure this breaks it.
Pretty damn sure though that you don't
because I Yeah, like you get
observation,
the environment returns you everything.
Observation, reward, yada yada. So, you
need to take the
you take all your reward predictions.
Try explicit normalization on the obs, I
suppose.
We have the KL here.
I changed the uh the free bits to 0.2
which seem to help a little bit
and it keeps the loss just above 2.
And when you go to hallucinate
trajectories,
new state, zero actions
state a prep. Yes, this is fine.
And then you either use if it's a
terminal, you get real observations
otherwise you get hallucinated
observations.
Real observations you get encoder
otherwise you get dynamics. Yeah.
We sample logits.
Uh we detach H and Z so that the
gradient cannot go from the actor to the
world model. This made a huge difference
in stability.
Terminal and reward are already trained.
Supervised. The only thing we need to
train is logic and value
dynamics and a representation loss.
Decode.
Yeah, the decoder is the um
Yeah, there is a decoder loss.
You do self policy, you reconstruct,
you have a full reconstruction loss,
mean squared error,
and then they do this wonky thing where
they make they try to make the encoder
and the dynamics match each other and
they do two different KL losses. This
[ __ ] thing.
My head hurts. Yeah, exactly.
I do not like this paper.
Yeah. Well, what do you do instead of
mean squared error on an arbitrary
reconstruction loss though, right? They
have it written as a log, but I checked
one of the implementations and like if
you tab through five layers of
horseshit, it's like they've literally
written a mean squared error and then
just named the variable log.
So, I probably should go to the original
code even though it's a mess because
there could be really important
discrepancies.
I mean, dude, what do you do on like
arbitrary obs?
You can't cross like there's no
there's no like cross entropy loss or KL
or anything you can write on that,
right?
I mean, this is like reasonably kind of
okay, I guess.
Is there a fast version of this we can
make work?
I mean, I guess
like so much freaking compute on
cartpole.
Uh, I think pretty much all of them you
see on the top right.
I've tried like 10xing the
reconstruction loss. I haven't tried on
breakout though. Maybe I should just do
more of this crap on Breakout.
that's cuz they're clipped, that guy.
So, anything that is um anything that is
below 0.2 gets clamped to 0.2.
I suppose I could do it in line instead.
I'll try removing the clamp here.
Uh if removing the clamp fixes this,
like yeah, they can go [ __ ] themselves
because this was in the paper.
It's weird because like basically this
means that these functions just don't
get trained at all.
No, it's not. It's the opposite that
guy. It's that when they're that high,
they literally do not get trained.
So it's actually it's the opposite of
that
and now like they are getting trained
now I suppose.
Hard to say if this is better yet.
It has to stay above seven, like stay
consistently above seven for it to be
above random PF or above like trivial PF
rather.
I mean, I could do this and 10x the
reconstruction loss, I guess.
Oh, the freaking zero entropy. You see
that?
Zero entropy on the policy.
Yeah, I'd like to sweep the losses, but
like I literally with all the manual
fiddling, I haven't gotten anything to
be above random perf. Like you need you
need some sort of starting point, right,
before you can really sweep
the it gets zero entropy as well. And
it'll do that often on some like on ends
even with a huge uh entropy coefficient
is ridiculous.
I don't even know how it does that
either.
I mean like it can't train now, right? I
mean, I guess theoretically it could
regain the entropy,
but it's like not it's not like
everything's nanned out or something.
It's just like fullon entropy crashed.
And I have not ever found an explanation
as to why.
The entropy does come back, oddly
enough.
It could just be the reconstruction loss
being um
I could do this type of a thing.
You're not going to do it.
No, I kind of want to just get
art pull stable
uh with more fresh data
because this like
this thing is ridiculous the way it is.
like
it that could literally be random.
The reconstruction loss is appropriately
lower at the very least. like I 10x the
loss uh coefficient and it goes it
optimizes better.
Right. So there's like high data regime
cart pole
I do start the repo. Thank you very much
for the advertising here. Bad. Folks, do
star the repo. It helps me out a ton.
It's free.
back to high data regime. We know that
we can go lower data regime with the the
way that this algorithm is set up,
right?
150 without the clamps.
I clamp to 0.2.
right. So, I mean, this clamp just seems
bad
to me at least.
At least now we have a fast way to play
with this. Corruption
Okay, 10xing reconstruction laws.
Terrible. Just make sure I didn't break
anything
No, I mean it's like 130 to what it was
before.
What about the world model loss?
Just the relative balance.
Okay. I mean, but this doesn't make the
huge huge difference, right?
Oh, I do
Okay.
I don't think I can get away with
putting this too much higher,
but I do think that you're supposed to
train the world model more.
the RL policy.
Yeah, it's going to get more and more
unstable, I think.
Okay. Honestly, it's not even like this
huge huge difference either.
I don't think it's just the balance at
least.
I mean, it's also like,
do we honestly expect this to do as well
as quickly?
Do we see anything with the rewards
being wonky?
I can't look at this. But what is this
here happening? What the heck?
No version of this stupid thing is
stable.
Flaps down again.
Not what we're doing.
could not run CUDA on a fresh install.
Yeah. So, what happens there is uh you
need CUDA dev. You probably just have
CUDA runtime
and you need um like CUDA dev uh the
CUDA dev build.
And the reason for that is that we have
custom uh a custom CUDA kernel that
needs to be compiled. You just need a
CUDA compiler, right? You need NVCC. If
you have NVCC, it should work.
can't figure out how to reoptimize
itself either, which is even worse.
Good. This isn't going to help. But else
do we do?
I'm kind of out of ideas.
I've checked this pretty thoroughly.
I don't think we've seen a single thing
that's made this stable this entire
time.
What happens if I make the replay
smaller?
I mean like maybe a little worse but
like
I mean, we've seen that this definitely
is not just a pure function of the uh
the replay buffer as well, right?
What is there left to even do?
I'm sure this isn't anything, but I'm
out of ideas.
Let me see if there's anything from that
Reddit post.
scalers
two hot plus sim log decoding mandatory
MA KL collapse needs clamping.
Imagination drift
pop sim log decoding mandatory don't
believe that
I tested that extensively
it six?
Yeah, it's already six. I'm working on
this all day.
Crazy.
Well, I got to go get dinner.
We've made some progress, I suppose,
today.
It's brutal, though. Absolutely brutal.
If anybody else has any ideas on like
what is actually required to get this
thing consistent and stable, please let
me know. Uh it's like in the pretty much
latest thing is in like onpaul world
model onpaul wm branch of the GitHub
for the folks who have been watching all
day or watching for the past few days of
this like nightmare
thing. This is just how research goes.
Uh all the literature's a mess. All the
reference code is a mess. I'm going to
have to start like looking through the
actual original code even though that
one's even worse. and I'm going to go
from there. If you're interested in my
work generally,
buffer.ai for all the things.
Try the repo. It's free. Helps me out a
lot. Join Discord if you want to get
involved. And other than that, you can
follow me on X for more RL content,
including a bunch of articles you can't
find anywhere else. I am going to keep
working on this at least for a decent
while because uh we need some version of
an algorithm that lets you scale more
data or more compute instead of more
data. This is the most promising
candidate. There are adjacent pieces of
work that are similar and even more
complicated to implement. Uh I don't
think anybody really knows what the hell
they're doing in this space, frankly,
because I know for a fact all the code
bases are a total mess and none of the
experiments are controlled. And we're
going to change that, but it's going to
take a while. And I'm hungry, so I'm
getting dinner.